this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm here today to talk about
mushrooms and international development
I was able to travel to two unique
locations in the world Bangladesh and
Rwanda Bangladesh was not all about
mushrooms I did go fall in love I went
to go visit my girlfriend Amanda while
she was collecting her data for her PhD
thanks Amanda but it was also for
adventure you know there's a lot of
lessons that you can't learn in the
classroom and you can't find in the
library and so I was really excited for
these sort of experiential learning
opportunities and then you know I'm
interested to get into international
development and I asked dr. Peter Hobbs
who some of you may know I asked him how
I could become involved in international
agriculture development he said Brian
you just got to do it you just got to go
there and get experience and do it and
so I went and that's that this is also
sort of an opportunity for my own
shameless self-promotion I'm going to
hopefully graduate this may so I'll be
looking for a job anybody knows a good
good opportunity i'd be happy to
entertain that so let's start by
combating stereotypes about mushrooms
mushrooms are the fruiting body in the
kingdom fungi fungi their own unique
kingdom there are a number of players
the good the bad and according to George
Hudler note no uglies right and there's
a number of uses number of ways
different mushrooms and fungi can
contribute to society in terms of human
health and ecological health so yeah and
then you know one stereotype we
encounter a lot here in the university
is the psychedelic mushrooms so if you
guys need to get it out of your system
maybe make a joke to your neighbor
really quick and then we can move on
from this stereotype mmm so I first
became interested in mushrooms and
reading this book mycelium running by
Paul Stamets Paul Stamets is a he's a
rock star mycologist really very
persuasive and sort of convincing all
the benefits that mushrooms can provide
to society some of the benefits
including include the remediation of
agriculture run off on the top you see a
number of mushroom species and it's kind
of small trust me they're there and then
a number of potentially disease-causing
organisms that are often the result of
wildlife and in rain water runoff and so
these mushrooms were incorporated into
riparian buffers have the ability to
kill a number of these pathogens some of
which are beginning to develop
antibiotic resistance they've also
certain mushrooms are also capable of
remediating chemical chemical
contaminants as a result of industrial
activities what's really neat about
these mushrooms is that they have the
ability to metabolize these chemical
contaminants rather than just absorb and
translocate as is common with more
traditional bioremediation strategies
plant-based bioremediation strategies
and so you see things in here like
organophosphates pesticides try not to
toluene that's TNT so this is you know a
remarkable way to use a living organism
to sort of fix the damage we as humans
have done to the environment mushrooms
can also be used as pesticides the most
expensive mushroom in the world is a
member of the cordyceps genus which is
pictured here it affects caterpillars in
the Himalayan plateau and Central Asia
like I said this is the most expensive
mushroom in the world there's also
certain quarter subspecies that will
infect ants grasshoppers can really help
to reduce economic reduce populations to
below and economic threshold mushrooms
are also very beneficial in human health
they have a great ability to bridge the
gap between foods and medicines there
are a number of different disease
and disease pathologies that they've
been associated with affecting I've got
citations for all of these if you'd like
to talk more about this later but really
they're you know there needs to be more
research done in to the applied aspects
of mycology it's a great way to sort of
bridge explore the interaction between
both human and environmental health so
on to the journey Bangladesh was first
became a country in 1971 before that it
was known as East Pakistan after the
1947 British partition but due to a
number of factors not the least of which
was Geographic separation Bangladesh
fought for their independence and gain
that in 1971 there continue to be a
number of political issues in Bangladesh
that have sort of affected it's coming
of age as a country but in addition to
the political turmoil Bangladesh is also
the site of the highest concentrations
of naturally-occurring arsenic in the
world and it's affects the soil and
groundwater and it has been described by
some as a public health emergency close
to fifty percent of Bangladesh
population is at risk of exposure and
traditional strategies rely on the
filtration from water which is
significantly inhibited by access to
financial resources in terms of getting
this technology out to the people who
really need it so in doing my research
for my master's degree I came across
this paper mitigation of arsenic
mediated stress and rats and while it is
a big jump from rats to humans this is
very promising and it's to the up the
light bulbs went off in my head and I
wanted to explore this more how can
mushrooms help Bangladesh so I traveled
the Bangladesh with two main questions
what is the current state of mushroom
activities in Bangladesh from an
extension standpoint and then our
specialty mushrooms an appropriate
strategy in preventing arsenic toxicity
and so for the first question I knew a
little bit of information going there
Amanda had traveled the Bangladesh and
in the year prior and wanted me to come
visit her the next time she would be
traveling to Bangladesh so I said hey
find something with mushrooms that I'll
be there and so she was able to come up
with the National mushroom development
in an extension center which engages in
research activities to promote a
national collection of useful mushrooms
human resource and agriculture
development training researching quality
parameters of products and production
tools to enhance branding and
verification expanding consumer
awareness in addition to increasing
consumer interest in order to develop
trade relationships for an export-driven
so that's that's what she found and I
was there to explore it I know in there
miss this is their mission statement
that I just read to you and they
described export driven development just
out of curiosity does anybody have any
opinion on the goal of export driven
development versus regional development
in terms of a novel crops such as
mushrooms it could be for anything
special to you know high-value
horticultural products I don't know if
anybody has an opinion on on that I
don't want to be the only one talking
here so
well right you can can you I mean the
goal of export is it exploitation its
let me set is in provide students for
the goal of an export driven development
opportunity are you exploiting
environment and people or can you really
help people with an export-driven go all
right anybody else that's sort of what I
think but I don't want to you know I
know some people believe in that export
driven development strategies of the way
the way to go so yeah I'd be happy to
talk with anybody after that after the
talk so the national mushroom
development and extension center
currently there are 16 sub centers
located throughout the Republic of
Bangladesh the center is in savar the
the main center the facility was started
in 1979 and experienced a significant
lag phase until 2003 when they began to
gear up production systems thanks to
grants from the Asian Development Bank
in 2009 the Japanese Development Bank a
gave another grant to the extension
center promoting their current capacity
of the 16 sub centers and making it a
part of the national extension system in
Bangladesh one thing I should mention is
that literally literally translated the
word mushroom in Bangla is frog umbrella
so that may give you sort of a hint on
how people will accept questions as a
food product so after arriving in Dhaka
we traveled to the Southern District of
New ockley and I hired a translator and
spent the time roaming the countryside
pursuing my own interest we found it
several former mushroom farmers no
current mushroom
farmers who told us that one when they
were selling mushrooms they would sell
for about two hundred taka per kilogram
fresh in two thousand talked up per
kilogram dry taka is the courtesy of
Bangladesh it's roughly 80 taka to a
dollar so this is a pretty high value
product and maybe not within the
purchasing capacity of many rural
households they mentioned that obstacles
to the expansion of their enterprise
included lack of acceptance of mushrooms
as a food product lack of profitable
market outlets and unreliability or poor
quality of spawn that was being sold to
them by the either the national
extension center or private enterprises
but there was promised that they
recognize they began to cultivate
mushrooms because they recognize the
unique properties mushrooms contain as a
food item one of the gentleman we spoke
to began cultivating mushrooms because
his father was sick and he wanted to
grow mushrooms because he thought the
mushrooms would help his father get
better and so you see this and the more
educated individuals that they can
recognize and understand the benefit
that that mushrooms can have in the
human body following our visit in new
oakley and there were a couple other
experiences in this region excuse me
while I was in wakulla we traveled to
Camilla which is another city in
Bangladesh and visited this Camilla
substation here they were currently
producing mushrooms they sold for 130
taka per kilogram fresh and 1500 taco
per kilogram dry and they explained to
me a little bit about the training that
growers must go through to be a part of
this extension system it's a three day
training program farmer farmers or
people are paid 600 taka to attend the
training and then they're given 25 free
spawn bags to begin their own enterprise
so you really you know there's really a
big push to get these farmers to attend
the meetings a great incentive
600 taco that's you know some of the
rural day laborers we talked with their
daily wages range from 200 taka to 500
taka per day and so this is you know
potentially three days worth of wage by
coming to this training session whether
they learn to grow mushrooms or not you
know they were there and they got paid
we were so once the farmers go through
the training maybe a week or two
afterwards the extension agents will
visit their farms and provide
troubleshooting advice if they aren't
able to sell their mushrooms than they
will the Extension Center will buy the
mushrooms from them usually in the dried
form at whatever the prevailing market
rate is during this time we were also
able to visit the Finney substation
Finney's another city in Bangladesh and
we I could on the way to this station we
came across a doctor I don't know he was
he been in the pharmacy trade for
roughly 25 years I don't think he he
hadn't been to formal medical school but
anyways he was referred to as a doctor
within the village and he prescribed
pharmaceuticals and he used a
pharmaceutical in his practice one drug
that was a mushroom derived product for
Myanmar in 2005 during the caretaker
government he wasn't able to access this
medicine and decide event that he would
grow his own mushrooms now mind you this
doctor was a former mushroom grower
again he cited limited market
development as his main obstacle in
developing his enterprise the nahr-e
Callaghan is the name of the sub centre
and feny it means coconut garden they
had a number of coconut trees is uh they
were evaluating four different different
parameters and so we got to eat a lot of
coconuts during this visit it was this
fun
and we talked to the director of the sub
Center who described a failure again a
failure of acceptance as a food item
lack of markets failure to create a
systemic production system and poor
retention of growers in the training
program and so we see this this big
national program but it's having trouble
getting off the ground and we'll talk
about some of the strategies in the next
but the next visit but one of the the
positive impacts of mushroom production
is that it can be done in sort of a
local village level a number of Muslim
communities women are confined to the
cloister or the group of houses that
surround their own household they aren't
permitted to travel to markets or leave
this tight village area and so mushrooms
you don't have to go out to the farms
you don't to go to the field to
cultivate mushrooms you can do it in
your backyard or next to your house and
so there have been a couple of papers
that suggest mushroom enterprise may be
a method of gender sensitive development
away to empower women in Bangladesh we
met with one woman this pictures I took
that picture that's not from the paper
we met with this woman who she was
engaged in mushroom production but said
that she didn't know if was a profitable
Enterprise because her husband took care
of all the financial matters so I guess
I posed the question is this really a
gender-sensitive opportunity or do they
need to tweak it a little so following
after a number of different experiences
later on in the fall I was able to visit
the center and savar and met with the
direct the national director of the
mushroom development program dr. neeraj
Chandra Shekhar in savar is the primary
stage of development they're trying to
establish processing and production
technology and they maintain a very
close relationship with India China
this is the source of all their germ
plasm for the mushrooms so these are all
exotic species that are being imported
into Bangladesh maybe if they were able
to isolate locally growing species that
may be more culturally adapted
environmentally adapted they may have
more success in their production systems
maybe the shape of the oyster mushroom
was throwing off consumers if they found
something more recognizable to them they
may want to eat it more but I think
there's really a big obstacle of
perception with mushrooms in Bangladesh
as a whole there are a number of
advertising programs on the radio and
television trying to promote the
benefits of mushroom as a food source
and people some of the people i talked
to suggest that this was making a
difference there's a few papers out
saying it's making a difference in
promoting mushroom consumption in
Bangladesh but I I'm still skeptical
that that they are actually making an
impact so just to conclude that section
a little bit Bangladesh harbors a very
robust Extension system for promoting
mushroom development but it's a very
top-down oriented program coming from
international entities to to the local
level
hmm well so I mean mushrooms can be
produced in a variety of scales and
methods and you can produce it on the
household level but you know here in the
United States they're all produced on a
big huge industrial scale you know I'm
not really sure why they chose mushrooms
as a development opportunity and why
it's received so much funding I mean it
very much seemed like they were trying
to force mushrooms on the population so
yeah but then here in the Chittagong
Hill Tracts reason and i'll talk about
this region a little bit more this is a
an area very high indigenous very high
concentration of indigenous ethnicities
that are probably more closely related
to the Burmese Myanmar folks than the
actual people that make up the
population of Bangladesh and they love
mushrooms you can find them in the
market you can find them you know people
are very eager and regularly consume
mushrooms so moving forward maybe the
Extension centers should concentrate
their efforts in this region I know
there's some tension between you know
the bungalows and and the indigenous
ethnicities in several areas but I was
actually had the opportunity to work
there working with a Spanish in geo and
I'll get to that in a little bit so
while i was in Noah we were able to
travel around and I wanted to develop
the agriculture context I want to learn
how farmers were how they farmed what
they used while we were in New ockley
this is dr. Chandra checker at the in
savar a few pictures of mushrooms that
they were growing there is the pink
oyster it's pink but it does really
taste very good so I don't know these
are reishi mushrooms being grown near
Fenny this was one of the most prolific
growers and
he had 2,000 of these spawn bags that
you can see and this is it's a rice
paddy straw so they take the harvested
rice and then the stubbles left in the
field and they harvest that there's also
some of the rice crops will grow or just
for the vegetative matter and not for
the rice use that too but you know one
of the great things about oyster
mushrooms you can grow it on just about
anything Stan kind of test you can grow
it on toilet paper rolls and growing on
coffee grounds and throw it on crude oil
it's really a very very interesting
mushroom this is in the penny office and
so we see that education was a big
factor in adoption of mushroom growing
technology so we could say that
mushrooms making more educated maybe
probably not but that education can
promote the adoption of mushroom growing
and consumption and so you know I think
we can suggest that an education program
in Bangladesh sort of as a whole for but
one of the complementary goals would
that would be that people would eat more
mushrooms and so education so like I
said I was able to spend some time and
no awfully talking with farmers learning
how they farmed in the markets market
vendors were generally very
knowledgeable about product origins they
can tell you what time it was from what
country it was from it was imported or
domestic and one problem is the
post-harvest storage and handling of
high-value perishable horticulture
commodities formalin used is widespread
in the value chain do you guys know
formalin it's used to preserve cadavers
highly toxic highly carcinogenic but
it's used to keep the produce from
rotting from the from them when they buy
it in the local market and try
support it to the urban market so we
talked about rural urban connections in
terms of urban food security but in
providing that food to the urban
populations there may be greater risks
there's also reports of people using
calcium carbide and a net to fajn for
fruit ripening both of which are not
permitted for edible crops and so
there's there is our public health risks
and turn it in the horticulture value
chain in Bangladesh that very seriously
need to be addressed and people
understand these risks and and do not
want to eat formalin contaminated food
it's unfortunate that it's mostly only
the upper classes that are able to avoid
this risk because grocery stores have
branded their products as formula and
free and will charge a premium and no
oculi we encountered a number of
non-governmental groups engaged in
agriculture and extension development
you see up top this is a focus group
organized by the nuclear oil development
society and this society performs duties
similar to an extension agent except
they focus on small holder farms they
provide seeds facilitate microcredit
opportunity organized farmers into
groups they provide tractors and arrange
for cooperation within regions and
disseminate information and technology
when we talked in this focus group the
farmers you know you ask farmers what
their problems are and you better have
your tape recorder on because they
farmers love to talk about how their
lives could be better they mentioned
very few storage options for perishable
goods that can't be sold at the market
winner is the most productive season for
them and but yet they're limited by
access to water resources it is winner
is the dry season in Bangladesh and they
like I said were you know you'd think
with this flooded all these flooded rice
paddies that water wouldn't be an issue
but in the dry season it can become a
very serious issue some other complaints
lack of transportation infrastructure
limited educational opportunities for
the children problems with soil salinity
and lack of access to capital down here
in the bottom left we were talking with
the gentleman who led an IPM club this
is a group of farmers who try to
disseminate sustainable technologies for
pest management things like pheromone
traps were very popular within this
group and the leader this is a
translated quote he said that waiting on
government extension service providers
is a dark hope so they've really sort of
given up on the government service
providers and providing extension
services to their agricultural
communities and so this was mind you
this was all in no ockley in the
Southern District and so upon hearing
this I said well hey why don't we go
talk to the extension officers so we met
with a new puzzle aquaculture officer
Mozilla's just one of their districts
sub-district do you know the hierarchy
can you rattle it off maybe some
somebody else knows
hey yeah so it's just how they arranged
okay okay so we met with the upazila
agriculture officer whose primary duties
this is self-reported primary duties
include thank you include fertilizer
distribution reporting on agriculture
activities and monitoring the block
officers and so why is a government
agent involved in fertilizer
distribution they can probably well
anyways but this agent was not from the
region he wasn't from luckily he was
from another part of the country he
doesn't know the region very well you
know some of his main problems he
advises farmers on pest management
strategies but many farmers will come in
with what they think are pest management
issues really turned out to be soil
nutrient deficiencies but there's really
a lack of soil testing facilities in
Bangladesh you know most of the farmers
will receive get their advice from the
local shopkeeper and the shopkeeper his
first question is isn't what is your
problem you know what have you done the
first question is how much money do you
have and so the shopkeeper will sell the
farmers a product based on not on their
problems but how much money they have
and so if they've got a lot of money
he'll sell them an expensive chemical or
product if they're a fee that doesn't
have a lot of money and he won't these
are a list of the pesticides that farmer
said they were using in no ockley I want
to highlight one right here lindane is
been banned in everywhere every part of
the world except for India and
Bangladesh in addition to killing
insects it also kills people
so it's been discontinued for sale in
the United States we found one farmer
that was using it some of the other
problems as many of the farmers can't
read and so you have these highly
technical pesticide labels and they
aren't able to understand that the
directions and how to apply these
pesticides certainly there's no PPE
personal protective equipment but you
know they're very readily available
there's um you know probably three
chemical and seed shops to every small I
mean every every locality after talking
with the vo pessoa agriculture officer
we went and found the plant protection
officer who described he said his duties
were organizing farmer training he also
grants the pesticide shop licenses he
says farmer training are organized into
small medium and large farm groups about
seventy percent of the farmers into
oculi following this small group small
farm group 25 and the medium and five
percent in the large landless farmers
sharecroppers are grouped into the large
farmer group which I don't know if that
makes sense or not AG subsidies in
Bangladesh are distributed by the
Ministry of AG fertilizer there's four
basic subsidies fertilizer and pesticide
are the entirety of the monies directed
to the Bangladesh chemical industry
association diesel and equipment
subsidies are direct deposited into
farmers bank accounts by the Ministry of
Ag so a farmer needs to have a bank
account to be eligible for this money
their subsidies to see it in seedling
producers which is directed to the
Bangladesh agriculture development
commission and then there's
price-setting subsidies for rice and
pulse products don't miss anything it's
it great
so following we did get to visit Asha
ganj I'm saying that right I don't know
great so and here we found a almost a
success of the extension workers I
talked with the district Assistant
District Supervisor the extension
activities in this for this area you
know we talked with a number of
different farmers who none of them
complained everybody knew their block
officer they talked with the extension
agent I think you know but the dist the
district officer said was that this
region is more industrially oriented
than agriculturally oriented and so I
think when we see a new oakley it's just
there's too many farmers I don't want to
say that right there's the the extension
officers are overwhelmed and here
there's an appropriate number of
extension officers to farmers and so
they can develop a more personal
relationship let's see some pictures
this guy was in the CNG with us CMG's
like a natural gas like a three wheeled
cart that you can take between villages
there's a man going around selling these
snakes he said that if he got bit he had
the vaccine so that he wouldn't get
poison I don't know it was really
interesting to see I mean rings him out
sort of smacks him around puffs up his
hood one part we visited had a pet deer
I don't know our dear common in
Bangladesh it is this like an endemic
think in the new oakley region you can
see it's one you can see it's wearing a
collar so this is clearly somebody's pet
yeah just that doesn't have anything to
do with anything just want to show you
the pictures so the Chittagong Hill
Tracts during my time in Bangladesh I
was able to get a consulting position
with a Spanish NGO working in this
region my specific I was an agriculture
technical expert where
on rainwater harvesting techniques for
dry season agriculture it was part of
their project to strengthening
socio-economic rights of indigenous
women in the region when I took this
position on I I don't know it didn't
have a lot about rain water harvesting I
think people had thought that they would
have written you know the rain barrels
from the harvesting runoff from
buildings and things like that number of
the buildings in this area were thatched
roof knots 210 roofs that Harbor a
number of microbial contaminants so and
at this point I really became aware of
Cornell not just as a brand and you know
recognizable name but there's actually
professors here that are here to provide
help when you need it dr. Norman up off
and dr. Peter Hobbs and a number of the
staff here provided some incredible
resources that helped me in this
position and so essentially what we were
doing the that we're working in the
llama Ali Kadam area it's characterized
like I said by high populations of
indigenous groups household income is
dependent on agriculture the traditional
system of cultivation is called Jim or
jus may it's a shifting cultivation
otherwise known as slash and burn some
of the villages due to increasing land
pressure these villages would
traditionally have a 30 to 50 year now
because of increased land pressure
they're shorten to 325 so the soil and
the ecology doesn't have a chance to
recover this soil organic matter and so
nutrient capacity and so there you've
got serious problems with erosion and
loss of livelihoods almost because they
fall into this cycle of poverty where
traditional cultivation practices result
in reduced soil fertility decreasing
vigor of crops and their resulting
progeny all of these villages save their
seeds further contributing to lower
productivity
resulting in reduced wages and food
insecurity and so my goal was to
encourage more perennial systems this is
a companion planting guide that we gave
to the so I was working with a local
implementing agency taranga I think is
what they're called and they had their
own agriculture officers so I was
helping the train the agriculture
officers who would then disseminate this
information to the local villages and in
determining projects to implement can
you guys see that in determining
projects to implement we were able to go
around and interview the villages you
know I tried to engage in a
participatory approach to determine who
needed what what their needs were and
work together we introduced a number of
solutions that came from this
publication if you can see that
implementing integrated natural resource
management projects under the Natural
National Rural Employment Guarantee Act
the National Royal Rural Employment
Guarantee Act is an act in India that
basically provides a 100 days of paid
labor to rural world people and so there
were a number of strategies for
rainwater harvesting and soil water
retention that came from this
publication that took place in in
eastern India very close right on the
Bangladesh border so appropriate
technologies that have been developed in
a similar region and then we introduce
these to the localities and they were
able to decide what they wanted to do
there were some cost sharing
arrangements with the implementing
organization and the locality so it
wasn't just sort of a donation here
we'll put in you know upon for you for
nothing it was the villages were engaged
in the problem and the solution and
oftentimes paid to pay for their labor
to work so a number of the strategies
were based on the slope of the land we
encountered all of these different
slopes with in the villages some people
a few of the more isolated villages
we're living in
exclusively on this a percent and
greater slope area but then like I said
a number of different slopes and each
strategy depends on the slope for its
public strategies to try and just hold
the soil hold the ground hold the water
in and Syria in serious moisture events
and here's pictures from the region this
is my my friend Nico this is a pond we
dug or helped to dig with with one of
the local groups you can see this is
maybe two or three days after we dug the
pond and it's already got more than a
metre of water in the bottom of it this
is a gully plug this is the same village
which so when when the rain falls you
get these channels could being cut out
of the hill and these gully plugs are
put in place to slow the ground slow the
the water so that it reduces erosion
eventually you'll get like the soil will
build up behind the gully plug and
you'll have a flat space to cultivate
your crops it's full of this rich
organic top soil that has fallen from
the rest of the hills and so you know
these are some of the strategies we
worked with and again like I said you
know mushrooms were commonly consumed in
this area but I didn't really see the
presence there are I think two of the
Extension centers in this area to travel
by foreigners is difficult it's
regulated you have to get a special pass
to enter the Chittagong Hill Tracts and
you are not supposed to be working when
you're there this was all volunteers so
I wasn't working per se but it's it's a
there's a lot of turmoil in this region
that I don't really want to get into
right now so just sort of reflecting on
my experience in Bangladesh it was I
mean it was a great country I had a
wonderful time I had a lot of great
experiences but I think in terms of the
mushrooms it you know it was very
top-down oriented approach
so in in Rwanda I worked for a US aid
hort crisp trellis fund that sounds like
a lot it's critical crisp is critical
research support program and the trellis
fund engages graduate students provides
funds for them to travel for two weeks
to 13 14 different countries I mean you
only get to travel to one country and
work with one NGO in that country I was
paired with sustaining Rwanda youth
organization and they had identified
mushroom cultivation as a mechanism they
were hoping to improve household food
security and provide rural enterprise
for one village that they work with and
near boot re the southern in the
southern region and so when I arrived in
Rwanda I spent the first week traveling
to a number of different much people
engaged in the mushroom industry
mushrooms are very popular in Rwanda
it's considered a high-value food item
that's associated with significant
cultural events sunday Sunday's
everybody goes to church the family day
they eat mushrooms for Easter or other
religious holidays baptisms they'll eat
mushrooms and so you know it was once
very expensive but now it's about half
the price of meat in the market and it's
it's quite readily available so this is
a group we met with that had their own
mushroom lab everybody called the veins
moister mushroom because it's the
easiest to grow this group was started
from what's called a seed fund from the
UN Development Program to start their
own enterprise they they do grow some
mushrooms but mostly they're to test
with education and they work with a
couple groups throughout the country to
that are more technically oriented but
this group was very educational oriented
kigali farms is a probably our most
helpful partner in rwanda they're trying
to like it says bring affordable high
entire crop
to rwanda the i think is the COO of
kigali farms was a former CFO of
ommegang brewery just down the road in
Cooperstown so he asked me to bring him
a bottle of the abbey ale that we shared
when we met up but they're trying to
provide the this is really neat because
they were trying to promoting mushroom
cultivation in rural areas and then
buying a mushroom and providing a
marketplace they have solar dryers to
extend the shelf life of the mushrooms
so they can impact in excess more
markets the end producers was probably
the biggest mushroom producer mushroom
distributor they're a wholesaler in
rwanda they they had a retail outlet and
probably the biggest market in Kigali
the capital city although we did fight
hear rumors that they weren't actually
paying their growers that they were just
taking the mushrooms and writing an IOU
in near boot re there's the rabona
agricultural experiment station this is
a partnership with the Chinese
government and a demonstration of
Chinese agriculture technology this is
the media sterilizer they were using to
sterilize their bags they use an
elephant grass media is what they call
it really tall guy you can see in the
background here you know it grows 11 12
feet tall these are the spawn bags that
they were cultivating this is so this is
a um subsidized you know these bags are
way below the market price for other
other you know Kigali farms produces
spawn bags and they sell them for 400
Rwandan francs for a bag the rabona
Experiment Station sells them for 301
and francs per bag and they probably
don't eat it you know they don't have to
sell them for that they could give them
away and they do especially when it's a
program targeted for rural enterprise
development after we visited all the
farms so if you see here one thing I
learned in visiting these farms was just
sort of how they grow mushrooms in
Rwanda because mushrooms require
moisture capacity high moisture content
it's very difficult to control to create
a controlled atmosphere and so they'll
put the mushrooms bags into the soil and
so they can regulate soil moisture much
better than they could regulate
atmospheric moisture and so I offered a
training I spent about an hour talking
what is a mushroom providing marketing
advice and production technical
production advice and then we built a
pilot plot behind this community church
so that women could see how to grow
mushrooms we gave them maybe 50 bags to
cultivate as a community the training
was targeted at a women's cooperative
and Roland is a very sort of cooperative
country they the women are there
identified as having malnourished
children are invited to attend a
maternal and child feeding class it's a
ten week class and after completing the
class they are invited to join the
cooperative and when you become a
cooperative in Rwanda you're given a
savings account and formally recognized
by the Rwandan government you're given
like a certificate and so you know they
have a savings account for which they
could promote microcredit activities and
it was targeted by the sustaining Rwanda
youth organization for a number of rural
enterprise activities and so following
the training we we bought some mushrooms
and brought them to this training and
the women we all cook them together and
then shared lunch after following the
training they make a really nice sort of
curry mushroom curry with peanut flour
onions and tomatoes some other rural
enterprise that we witnessed in in
Rwanda this is a wooden cup it's
intricately carved very nice this is all
sorghum that's being malted they do a
lot of home brewing and beer production
and in the rural areas of Rwanda I
didn't try any I don't know if I regret
that or not
and so just sort of reflections on the
Rwanda experience market access and our
specific project was limited by
household consumption so I don't know if
that's a bad thing or not it sort of
effects the sustainability of the
project because they aren't able to
generate income but they're also getting
a nutritious food source in their
household so you know goes goes back and
forth the sustaining ruined a youth
organization the director and some of
their volunteers you know I was with a
different volunteer every day which was
nice but they weren't able to develop
the technical capacity that they needed
to encourage this enterprise in Rwanda
there were some serious issues with
termites so I was able to suggest
biocontrol options I don't know if they
were able to get ahold of those
biocontrol options or not and so it's
really difficult to determine what
impact my time in rwanda made that the
people in Rwanda it was a profound
experience for me but I don't know what
impact I had in the locality comparing
the two Rwanda was a little bit easier
to work I feel like the you know there
are some very serious ethnic issues in
Rwanda but the government has made laws
saying that you cannot differentiate
between the ethnicities in public media
and so you know the Rwanda experience in
their histories tragic and I think
they're really looking forward to look
beyond that and really work together at
being one rwanda so I don't know but the
legacy of mushroom consumption in Rwanda
was was very important in speed as a
high-value product with a considerable
demand looking to the future I think
more work on monitoring and evaluating
mushroom enterprise especially in Rwanda
is important there's a lot of
information right now about biochar
whether it works or not people have
different views
but in planting the mushrooms in the
soil like we saw in Rwanda you really
are increasing the soil organic matter
and could potentially pave the way for
more perennial cropping systems such as
tree fruits and agroforestry related
systems and then you know what is the
role in the government other agencies I
wrote inhibiting up there because you
know is in subsidizing their spawn bags
is the Rwanda Extension Service are they
inhibiting appropriate market
development and then how do you
introduce innovation to a rural
community without having them be
dependent on your own you giving input
you know the women they after they ate
all the mushrooms they said okay can we
have some more spawn bags now they said
well we don't have any money so i think
the project sort of ended at that you
know how do you how do you introduce a
new idea without the people become
independent on your inputs so that's all
I've got today thank you for coming out
does anybody have any questions
but do you think that these
opportunities in any status entities
containing water is there is there any
additional a better image or yeah
probably you know I you look at em in
terms of Agriculture inputs you know
there's pretty heavy transportation
costs that are associated with organic
inputs there's a lot of ammonium nitrate
available in Bangladesh and so as you
know to sort of differentiate like the
you know agriculture mushrooms excuse me
you know for agriculture inputs I think
it'd be difficult you know and then I
don't know how do you incorporate it
into sort of a market-based system to
get it out to the people i mean there
definitely could be opportunity i just
don't know what it would be
for real estate you know how their
development programs that introduce
different crops there's like a pair
right so vegetable consumption and in
Bangladesh was not very common you know
around the time of their independence my
understanding is that once people
started working going to Saudi Arabia
and other countries to seek employment
they say you know they started bringing
back the tradition of vegetable
consumption and so you know in that way
it's more of the organic sort of
ground-up adoption of these habits I
don't know if there would be a education
program that could combat the obstacle
perceptions of mushrooms and motives is
that what you're asking
yeah Bangladesh is a very densely
populated country and so space is a as a
constraint so that's why we were always
seeing substrate cultivation plus you
know a lot of the yeah a lot of the what
is used for fuel for cooking fires and
so there's not really that abundance of
forest resources that we see here mmm I
mean in Bangladesh everything's gotta
use it seems like and so you know to be
able to identify a substrate and
appropriate substrate I think it's
difficult yes sir
excuse me the Noriko begun is anthony oh
I did go to like cold storage well so
the I mean that was one of the answer
your second question first you know
farmers were selling their mushrooms
within in their village you know there
were significant obstacles of
transportation and when you know in
these sort of village units they're able
to educate the there the other villagers
about the benefits of mushroom and so I
think in that way they're able to
develop these market mechanisms they
they still were not sufficient to you
know that I talked to more former
mushroom farmers than current mushroom
farmers so you know something
something's not working and then and
then we did visit savar I spend the day
and so far talking with the national
director of the program but yeah I mean
so I did a good visit so I
yeah thank you will help your sky help
yourself to cookies and coffee thanks
for coming out
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu